hey guys you may say just seeing what
are you doing if you hit a new low
potentially but don't ask questions
because today we are here to cut soap
apparently this is a very popular thing
to do on YouTube so I thought hey why
not jump on the bandwagon that's what we
do here except some people don't film
dead bodies on YouTube so did you say I
think that's one bandwagon that probably
most people will be jumping on but the
soap on the other hand let's do this
I've also got a slow-mo soap cam right
here and we're gonna cut it I don't know
if there's an edit kit to this but I've
got the slo-mo cam here so we're gonna
have some slo-mo soap cut I also ordered
on Amazon Prime now a new cutting board
because the one that I had I didn't like
so midway through this video I should be
getting a bigger cutting board cuz this
is all pun intended not gonna cut it
oh gosh I'll be here for the next 5 to
10 minutes but what we need to do now
was we gotta get some knives because if
you guys are new here you don't know
that I love knives welcome to my channel
so they need my cooking knives they're
very dull because I owe use them to open
things and boxes and stuff so we're
gonna set these off to the side so this
is my bowie knife this is probably one
of my favorite knives that I own I do
have a lot of smaller ones that I like
as for the larger knife I really love
this one I've used this to cut cakes and
other things but today my friends we're
gonna cut soap with it which soap should
i do first
Nik do you have a preference okay I
don't know what the etiquette is I feel
like people would like really chopping
and getting into it but I'm gonna do it
my own style I'm gonna cut this over
however I want to cut the soap so first
I'm just gonna maybe just give it a nice
jab oh you see in this piece oh wow wow
wow wow let's just hope that I am NOT
going to end up in the hospital after
that says Shh Wow soap is super slippery
is that what people are into is that
something that happens I'm gonna cut it
am i doing
that's a cut that's a cut
I feel like this is one of those things
where what I think back to my childhood
when people were like just see what do
you want to be when you grow up
oh boy
[Music]
Shh this is entertainment this is fun
you just don't get us Nick you just he
doesn't get us guys I'm curious as to
what you thought I was doing I thought
you were gonna like craft the bars are
so Vince you like the shape or something
you don't melt those down into another
bars no I'm literally cutting so you're
asking way too many questions you don't
understand
yeah the culture so let me break it down
for you yeah I think you're just fine so
that's it that's actually what I'm doing
no you know I'm enjoying this commentary
Elise X I'm gonna talk to you while I'm
cutting myself this smells very good so
the scent of this it's like a minty
raspberry it like kind of smells it
smells so good I want to eat it so for
our next soap I'm gonna switch it up a
little bit I'm gonna maybe use a smaller
knife just to see how that feels maybe I
might like it more maybe I might not I
don't know what this is it's a blue
chunk but it's really beautiful so now
let's cut it
[Music]
thank you Oh God
I'm very sensitive to like smells and
man has this making me sick this it's
like some sort of ocean breeze nonsense
I have seven soaps left I'll use a
smaller knife so I decided to use this
one I usually use this to cut bread or
open up Amazon boxes so we'll see how
this cuts look at that texture Wow we
guess let's hear a new cutting board
this is gonna look so much better we
just upped our game this stinks it's not
discussed it smells like shame and need
like a bucket new cutting board what do
you things look good now we're on to our
next soap
[Music]
next knife look at this little one is a
little carrot oh you guys like this one
look at this real Chuck real fast chalk
oh look at this
mmm that smells actually that's most
pretty good this looks like something I
would eat this looks like a little
muffin
let's give it a big chop give you the
treatment
[Music]
I think smaller knife works better for
the effect that we're trying to get this
looks like a salad I think you guys are
gonna be super into this soap it's a
very bubbly soap so I'm gonna be
completely honest with you guys I'm
getting a headache from the scent of
this soap all of this is definitely
giving me a headache
two soaps left I have a lost son of you
guys yet are you confused I'm also
confused but we're gonna try to do two
soaps at the same time why not look at
that
[Music]
well guys today we cut soap if you
enjoyed this or if you didn't enjoy it
I'm probably gonna do it again because I
want to get my sister in here to see
what she thinks about cutting soap this
is so strange and weird but in some
weird way it was actually kind of
relaxing just cutting soap I wish that I
wasn't so sensitive to these smells
because it's making me slightly nauseous
so thank you guys for watching I will
see you in my next video if you haven't
subscribed already you know what to do
and if you don't then probably shouldn't
be using YouTube what if I put all this
soap into the bathtub should I try it I
probably should try it I should try it
why not what have I got to lose my house
my skin my dignity I've got a lot of
things to lose it's not happening okay
bye
[Music]
[Applause]